Hello.
I, uh wanted to make a statement on what I said in my previous live-stream
You probably won't believe me when I say this,
but whenever I go online and I hear other players
use the same kind of language that I did,
I always find it extremely immature and stupid and
I hate how I now personally fed
into that part of gaming as well.
It was something that I said in
the heat of the moment.
I said the worst word I could possibly think of.
And it just sort of slipped out.
And I'm not gonna make any excuses as to why it did
Because there are no excuses for it.
I'm disappointed in myself because It seems like
I've learned nothing from all these past controversies.
And it's not that i think I can say or do
whatever I want and get away with it.
That's not it at all.
I'm just an idiot.
But that doesn't make what I said or how I said it okay
It was not okay.
I'm really sorry if I offended, hurt or
disappointed anyone with all of this.
Being in the position I am, I should know better.
I know I can't keep messing up like this.
And I owe it to my audience and
to myself to do better than this
because I know I'm better than this.
I really want to improve myself and better myself
Not just for me, but for anyone that looks up to me.
Or anyone that's influenced by me.
And that's how I want to move forward away from this.
That's all I had to say. Thank you for watching. Bye.